[Music]
everybody talks about the Mamba
mentality that's what he was with the
13th pick in the 1996 NBA Draft the
Charlotte Hornets
select Kobe Bryant it's not enough words
in my vocabulary I'm a burden ocular
describable Kobe means to me but he's
been a tremendous mentors tremendous
person and I'm very sad that he's gone
and I read one of his quotes and he said
some days I feel like nah I just want to
give up but in those moments like you
can't let that moment take you down you
just got to keep going you got to push
yourself you got an embracing ride my
wanting on the item give me everything
to me now I looked up to that man more
than anybody
which left the legacy which is hard to
do amongst millions and that legacy will
live on the pumping mentality means
you're willing to go past which we even
thought you can go fast it's pushing
beyond limits willing to work as hard as
you possibly can to to attain a level
that is unreachable in the minds
everyone knows how special about athlead
he was but in these last couple days to
hear the type of father he was and to
know that happened with his 13 year old
daughter and the other seven people is
real tough thing to think about it makes
you appreciate all your loved ones it
makes you want to value every moment his
mentality was special and as an athlete
as a father it never changed don't ever
question the heart and the emotion the
grit
[Music]
that guy
[Music]
the fierce competitor man you know he
never wanted to be second to no one the
way he attacked the game the way he
challenged yourself the other horn for
the final time
[Applause]
this mentality was just unparalleled and
unmatched
there's no favor effective you know
especially the people from LA and people
we understand
you know there be a different world
without you don't make Kobe's legacy the
Mamba mentality they won't forever
[Music]
[Applause]
wait we got to do now
remember that legacy
my bow
[Music]
[Applause]